[Music]
5 25 on your wednesday morning if all
you want to know is when's the 95 515
going to get back to whatever normal is
well a new website from the nevada
department of transportation is driving
home the point
that it's going to be a while it's
called
nv515.com and it shows that what we're
in the middle of right now is just part
of
six different projects that may stretch
into the year
2030 so the big squeeze that we're in
right now will eventually be
overshadowed by what's called the
downtown access project that is going to
be a complete rebuild of the entire
freeway between the spaghetti bowl and
eastern that's the one that could take
you into the turn of the decade early
next year current plans call for almost
two years worth of repaving that's going
to be down around the 215 late next year
ndot's planning to redo just about
everything around the freeway at
charleston sometime in 2023
it'll be what's sometimes called the
hendersonville due for a two-year long
makeover last but not least much work
around the 95-515 at flamingo on the
calendar for 2025.
got the link to all these projects in
the online version of this story it's on
our website 8newsnow.com click traffic
than driving me crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
something driving you crazy email me
traffic 8 8newsnow.com